rus ya anunciado que va a restringir
todavía más el flujo de gas que
suministra a alemania la principal
economía de europa
alemania recibirá sólo una quinta parte
del flujo habitual y recordemos que el
país está allá bajo mínimos puesto que
ahora mismo está recibiendo sólo el 40
por ciento de lo que normalmente recibía
por parte de gazprom la razón que
esgrime moscú es que hay de nuevo
problemas con una de las turbinas
recordemos que había estado preparándose
en canadá pero desde la unión europea se
ha acusado a rusia y en varias ocasiones
de estar utilizando el chantaje
energético en todo caso la noticia llega
en un momento muy complicado para los
países europeos para todos ellos puesto
puesto que precisamente ahora es cuando
se están dedicando a llenar sus
depósitos de gas subterráneos de cara al
invierno